bring in Mike Tirico Golf Channel host
play-by-play duties for Westwood One and
NBC Mike good morning I was curious
listening to that the difference in
calling golf on radio and golf on TV Jim
Nantz laid out for two minutes and let
the pictures tell the story you know
you're a TV guy but here you are on
radio how tough is that that you want to
let us hear it but you also have to
describe it well I relied on my vast
experience of calling golf on radio but
as I listed back but during the
broadcast they play a lot of the final
putts from the history of the Masters
and Westwood one is broadcasted for a
long time and hearing all those they are
far different from the TV call and I
applaud Jim and Nick we were in a
similar situation when Tiger won the
career slam in 2000 just do a little and
lay out and when he won the Open after
his dad had passed away I said this
one's for pops and they didn't say much
after that and all the pictures are
telling the story but then you've been
in Augusta a whole bunch I've got to
tell you it was different the fans were
just so energized if at the end of that
call I lay out for a couple seconds you
hear the fans chanting Tiger Tiger I've
never heard that at any point at Augusta
not Arnold not Jack not anyone so that
it was a different moment it felt more
like the atmosphere at the end of a big
playoff football game than it did the
usual serenity of 18th grade the Masters
so it was a pretty pretty neat day I'd
say of the events I've had a chance to
be on the air for a call there's nothing
that matches what yesterday was all
about TV or radio yeah I try to describe
it for the audience if they haven't been
there even if you hear it on TV it's
still not the same there's just
something about hearing a roar and
there's a difference there's a tiger
roar and then there's a roar for
everybody else but I did wonder this
Mike I don't know if you did I kept
waiting for that defining moment if
Tiger did something truly spectacular
not you know maintain his course here
but
sixteen I thought once once he hit that
shot I just thought that everybody else
was dead after that did you have a
moment where you said this is Tigers
that was the moment when he hit that
shot and then then the reality said I'm
pretty quick that kept getting three now
were close enough and we had seen guys
making birdies I mean III Dustin Johnson
right in front of us the 18th green and
that's why we whispered we're only 15
yards from the players it's not like
we're in a tower that's 30 feet up and
closed in glass so we're close enough to
get be really careful Dustin Johnson was
very close to us and he had our
nine-foot good look at birdie they
wanted to put more leaderboard pressure
on Tiger I think that 16 moment was that
one defining moment where he said okay
now he can go play protect the lead and
try to win this and I think in a big
thing that I don't know how much
attention it's gotten the fact that they
were in threes chanted a little bit not
playing it too because Tiger ends up in
the last group he would not have been in
the last group and he wouldn't have been
able in all likelihood to play at the
18th the way he did protective knowing
that kept get didn't make birdie in
front of him so I think that's factored
into is a the way he played that last
that last hole for sure yeah that's a
great point we're talking to Mike Tirico
if I said you got jack or tiger what are
gonna take a number of majors when it's
all said and done what it's all said and
done man I said Tiger for a long time
and then I you know what I it when Tiger
so to have all of his issues it's okay
not gonna catch Jack we got it we
understand that now man i i stiii here's
why i want to say tiger because the last
three majors we've seen tiger has been
on sunday evening right there last seven
six holes tiger at the US US Open or
tiger at the Open Championship I should
say Tiger at the PGA and now the Masters
he's had a chance to win all three and
he won one of them so 18 is far more far
more realistic than it was six months
ago
farm work and you got these courses that
are still left on the schedule that
Tigers wanted they favor him as well I
saw where he's the favor going into the
PGA Championship
Mike I saw the odds for Tiger winning
the Grand Slam it's 50 to 1 it's never
happened before
little crazy I was laughing I thought
you were gonna say what I the same thing
I saw on supposed to be I think is on my
Twitter feed about an hour and a half
after I left the golf course the odds
for the 2020 Masters shoulders for a
minute but you know there's a market for
but then as you know and you said it a
bunch of times on the show here that's
the course the tiger has an advantage
and you saw it yesterday when Molinari
put the ball in the water on 12 Tigers
game plan is now hey I can go into the
fat of the green where if I miss hit it
I'm in the bunker either short or long
but I don't have to mess with anything
about the hole location and that comes
from playing 75 a hundred rounds of
Augusta National
in all these conditions that's why for
years beyond his best golf he'll still
have a chance at Augusta and I thought
of Tiger on 12 because Jack Nicklaus
would would say his logic his philosophy
was on 12 if the pin Sunday pin is on
the right far right just go right in the
middle of the green or to the left don't
do anything fancy and get your par and
get the hell out of there because that's
one of those where you walk away you
look at the hole and you go yeah that's
you know buck 48 this isn't a big deal
and then you won't walk away and you go
how did I end up with a 5 here back in
the 13 you go really yeah I'm gonna
throw it on that green you know you know
you brought up a really really good
point in and I think about Tiger it is
understanding of masters history and his
knowledge and he go through his entire
post round press conference he gave you
four or five windows into that one of
them was I'm standing on 11 green he
says I watched the guys put the ball in
the water and I know because their
trajectory and ball flight what they hit
and how they hit it I know the shot I
have to play oh wait you're doing all
this while you wait to putt at 11
that's why his 15th Club in the bag his
brain has always been the one when he
was physically good enough that
separated tiger from everybody else and
you saw examples of that throughout that
second line yesterday just just
incredible I didn't think we'd see this
again and as I gotta be honest it was
really
they cool to be a part of it and watch
it with your own eyes I never thought
we'd be there again telling that story
but if you look at the the social impact
and really the golf impact of 1997 but
then you look at the impact of this I
guess 97 stands out for you know more
you know for a variety of things but can
you compare the two that what he did
yesterday and what he did in 1997 the
impact of that or is it the impact more
yesterday's for Tiger 97 was on the
world that's good I like that angle to
it but here's the one thing so this
generation of kids and my son is just
about ecology if you have a daughter
who's a junior in high school they
they've heard all about Tiger and all
the wins and all the successes but now
they really got to see it with a full
understanding of it and I think then
this next generation the generation
that's now you know 15 to 23 24 if
they've only heard about Tiger and maybe
will put the golf on to see Tiger and I
think seen him at his best they
understand what the Tony female
generation and all those guys who were
6-3 6-4 who were attracted to golf
because Tiger made it cool they now are
feeling this so maybe there's another
generation if there's a little tiger run
here four to three years that we'll see
how cool golf can be when he's playing
and these other guys are hitting it all
over the place and that might be the
next Tiger bump but I don't think it'll
match the first one which we all thought
was going to be bringing more minorities
to the game and in fact it was bringing
more athletes to the game I'll leave you
with this oli is convinced Michael
Phelps is coming back for the 2020
Olympics and he's they're following
Tiger yesterday now the reason why we
think and Pauly thinks and we even said
it to Michael Phelps is because of his
son that that here's Tiger got to share
this with his son do you see that if I
said I bet Michael Phelps is gonna swim
a couple of races or he doesn't do
anything and he's an analyst for the
2020 games
i-i've been under the assumption that he
wasn't going to swim that he really he
put you put the goggles and the swim
trunks away which is in a very small
place if you hang those up I think I'm
about to get Treecko on my side I don't
know it sounds like he's hanging up his
speedo
aye-aye-aye now that you say it that way
was the Sun aspect of it okay how can
you not as a competitor be think of it
how about this you know tiger now is the
what's the one thing he hasn't done he's
never won an Olympic gold medal Tiger is
now high enough in the world rankings
that if you make the Olympic team right
now he would qualify so what is Tiger
and Phelps and Serena and Roger Federer
and LeBron all come from one last shot
at the Olympics in Tokyo in 2020 sounds
like a heck of a Nike commercial I know
that well it sounds like a promo for NBC
Sports Mike nice trying to talk to you
save travels and I'll talk to you soon
next time in New York I want to see the
new cave in person oh my god Mike it is
spectacular yeah yeah it's pretty
incredible really proud of it so we'll
roll it out on Friday come on a Friday
when we have meet Friday okay at some
point can I get a little bit of
memorabilia there like that head
shoulders adds at me you McKendree and
salad did can we get that just what just
once means right there yeah we heard it
I have that but you only want it up
because you had hair back then you're
correct it's in the green room of the
old place I hope we took it out of there
right yeah thank you Mike Tirico NBC
Sports Golf Channel host and
play-by-play duties for Westwood One for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app